okay
[Applause]
I'll try this word we miss it
I have a bad feelings
yeah enough
can't really smell anything over the
antifreeze
she fell asleep at the wheel
she's saying that
whenever she
she's coming around this way so she was
she lost control since she started
fishtailing and was like spinning so I
think she'd fall asleep and then
you wake up jerk and oh just over
correctly probably correct and just
start
going crappy
I don't know how long I've heard so far
is that she's told Kevin she fell asleep
at the wheel
so
we're gonna get some cones
Regina told me she said she fell asleep
at the wheel yeah
all right
over 40 dude
he's bleeding sorry
so from my understanding you've made it
to another option
and she's got lacerations on the back of
her legs
[Applause]
are your legs hurting including
okay
hmm
all right we're gonna have to sit down
because you're bleeding okay
and then we'll be right back with you
okay
we'll leave a limit for anybody under
the age of 21 is 0.02 okay
and so you are
[Applause]
they're gonna go over all that with you
okay
if you just want to have a seat for us
okay how's the family
that she had
um they're shaking up but I think
they're okay over there they were in the
ambulance uh it's in the ditch oh
stepdad
I've got to go do film sobriety on her
okay
um let me get my stuff done real quick
and then I'll let you talk to her but
more than likely she's going to be going
with me absolutely yeah y'all do what
you gotta drive back y'all homeless okay
I just she's I'm just upset but she's
fine right okay I just wanted to let you
know they said you was down here and I
didn't want you to
so let me go get my bit done real quick
and I'll come back when we're done I'll
get you to come talk to her for a few
minutes something like that okay okay
oh yeah
ever had a speeding ticket or anything
that's her first party I told her mom
don't let her go she went to a party
last night in Fayetteville
step down your stepdad yes sir she does
have insurance on the car uh liability
only okay well that'll cover the
Suburban she hit right
or I know the girl in the jeans and the
black top there on the right yeah her
car's at my house is it and if she's
fine if she can go I'll be able to take
her I don't have enough of the other
kids with her other kids with her no
they were it's just those two yeah the
other two that are talking to her they
were driving by or they were oh she
almost hit them too okay and they
stopped when she hit the other vehicle
she fall asleep or is it just the
drinking I don't need to say just you
know what I mean uh I'm not sure
initially she told us she fell asleep
but then she admitted to the other
officer she'd been drinking
uh I mean probably we're just up all
night
that and she
he smells you could still smell it on
her so getting a DUI because she's
underage
means that
she'll probably have her license
suspended until she's 21.
okay
yeah her stepdad has offered to give you
a ride back to his house since that's
where your car is right no drinking for
you no I think he's in the truck behind
it okay
well I'm sure he'd give him
off officer long but I think you should
be good yeah
get your foot down
put back up and begin
you understand okay
hang on don't start this yet
all right keep your hands down to your
side remember foot six inches off the
ground okay keep your foot parallel to
the ground there you go and you can
begin whenever you're ready
thank you
all right here's the deal
with the eye test for the idea and your
age
I believe and you're over the leading
limit to be driving so I want to place
you under arrest
[Music]
for me
do you have anything in your pockets
[Music]
no hang on
to that witness sleep down there from
down there the other end
uh yeah I believe so yeah I hope they
didn't steal my freaking because that
was one of my goodies
so
pins are a hot commodity when you're a
cop
yeah
um
her stepdad is willing to take them are
you cool with them going down to him now
as long as how old are you guys
oh my God I don't care as long as
they're yeah I mean of age parents I
don't care I mean they're 18 they do
what they want okay
yeah y'all can go down to her dad now
keys are in the car
is there any way we can get that yep
the name of that towing company so I
know where it is it's Royals but I'll
write it down for you I'll get a card
from him okay
gotta Davis
and then the keys to the Mustang are in
the ignition they'll have to have those
and then I don't deal with anything with
them do I the people should get no
insurance yeah we'll give them all that
information
[Music]
um
he probably doesn't have the card on her
I usually just keep it on my phone I
give it to them and they end up losing
it anyways yeah I understand it but we
do have liability on it do you know if
she has where she keeps her license by
chance
usually she has a keychain that's on her
keys and it's like a little okay I'll
see if I can find him not a wallet yeah
change first thing yeah my wife has one
I understand what you're saying but I
noticed it was another piece I think she
took it off because I just put a new
battery alternator on that yesterday
and uh so I think she's attached it just
happened with her okay
[Music]
do I need to do anything else I think
you're good boss
um okay yeah
if you have any questions or anything
just give us a call okay
yeah
[Applause]
they'll give her they'll usually keep
her for eight hours so they know she's
sober
but
as well
I don't know I've never done this
usually they'll sign her out on her own
the or to you which means no bond just
own recognizance but she has to go to
court so
that'll be September 21st at 10 A.M
just to give you a heads up
[Applause]
be safe and make the chicken I
appreciate it thank you appreciate it
we'll get that other girl back
and I'll let her drive
she said she wasn't but I don't trust
first party
I told her mom said not let her go
[Music]
but what were we doing when we were 18
yeah no answer to that yeah
all right let me get home thanks guys
yep be safe
get you up there because the sooner I
get you up there the sooner you can get
booked in okay
and you're not
okay just make sure you wasn't bleeding
anywhere else or nothing like that
oh hang on let me lock those I don't
want them to get tied on your wrist
okay
all right let's head this way
all right I'm gonna put you in over here
uh hang out right here for me let me get
everything unlocked
all right have your seat
once again I'm gonna buckle you in just
so
okay
[Music]
you okay sorry
all right go ahead and hop out
[Music]
need help
there we go
all right
let's go there
heavy seat right here in this chair it
may take them a second they got to come
out here and ask you some questions and
then they'll go in
[Music]
Kenzie
huh
well I think due to the adrenaline and
everything she she
not for her she's high but
[Music]
yeah she I think it feels like me
well she I think it's certainly is an
accident pretty bad one luckily no
luckily no one was hurt but I think it's
just the adrenaline dog
would be enough
[Music]
walking stick
w-a-l-k-i-n-g SDI it's like the walking
stick yeah
well I think she's crashing she's a
drinking dump and all that so
this is going on yeah you know you're in
the road right
you were how much you have to drink
tonight
a couple ah I think it's a little more
than a couple okay I'm not gonna lie to
you yeah well where are you headed
where are you coming from
my house
so you came from your house and you're
headed to your house yeah so what you
just started driving around in your
lawnmower yes sir yeah sir are you gonna
take me to jail or not no I didn't say
that I said we're gonna do some field
sobriety exercises I have been drinking
okay that's fine
I have been drinking I'm saying you told
me that well yeah good and that's in
like I said we're gonna do some
exercises just to determination no sense
in it why not because I've been to
drinking okay
are you gonna do it for me I'm on a
drive you're gonna try that's all I'm
asking for you to try
them I don't want you to fall though if
you think you're gonna fall okay
hold that position until I tell you to
do so
okay
listen to me yes sir I have no license
at all okay I have no driver's license
right
I know I do have an ID right I give you
my ID okay I'm trying to be a nice this
guy as I can so am I I'm trying to give
you the opportunity take me to jail I
cannot walk
like that
but why not
I've been drinking too much okay well
you gotta understand I gotta I gotta
determine based off what you show me so
far in the exercises we've done whether
or not
I take you to jail for that I understand
this right I really understand so these
exercises are to determine whether or
not
you're I have had maybe a little too
much to drink okay and you're operating
a motor vehicle essentially I don't know
we're on the side of the road you
weren't on the side I observed you in
the middle of the road
[Music]
and back there
just give me a ticket and be done with
that
so I'm gonna ask you one more time if
you want to do these exercises
all right Paul go ahead and turn around
put your hands behind your back
I drink
how you doing good good my name is
Corbin Prado Police Department do you
know I'm stopping tonight
because you ran a bicycle
is that what he says
red light
no so you were back on uh Lake Pickett
you were on the wrong side of the road
you almost struck the curb numerous try
at times you're running 15 yes you were
going 15 miles over the speed limit and
then when you made that left-hand turn
you almost ran off the road over here
where are you coming from tonight
downtown downtown
shift where do you work at
okay and we're headed to
right here you live a night Circle yes
you go to UCF yes hey how much you had
to drink tonight
one drink what will you drinking tonight
vodka vodka okay how big was the vodka
I'll make it wrong all right drug test
me right now okay well I'm not worried
about drugs okay okay well that doesn't
work that way okay so let me have your
vehicle registration proof Insurance
please okay
get that one let me have it please
thank you you've been what
two children
out of it okay where'd you go to jail
for I don't use your credit cards
following too close you went to jail for
following too closely
that's not an arrestable offense
what were you charged with
burglary
before it even made the states I don't I
don't need your credit card uh to step
out of the vehicle
okay come stand right by the front of my
car right there Olivia
what's in your hands
okay we don't need these I'm gonna put
these back in your car
uh where I was supposed to use the
restroom and I really have pizza
restrooms okay so uh here's the thing
I'm very concerned that you shouldn't be
operating a vehicle and I'm concerned
that you're operating a vehicle in the
State of Florida in the County of Orange
in the jurisdictional limits of the
University of Central Florida why you
are your normal faculties are impaired
by a chemical controlled substance do
you have any problems participating in
the standardized field sobriety
exercises for me no sir are you gonna
take care of a doctor of a dentist
um no okay are you diabetic or epileptic
I am I have panic disorder the panic
disorder okay do you take medication for
that yes what do you take
um I take a five milligram tablet and I
take a 10 milligram tablet of the best
women drone
so you take 15 milligrams of that one
one drug 10 milligrams twice a day five
milligrams total
twice okay so in the morning you want to
take two five milligram tablets correct
controlling 10 milligrams okay is that
the only kind of prescription you're on
and the five milligram tablet of a like
medical how do I describe it um muscular
go ahead with it
what's it for a muscular it's for
endometriosis okay
other than those two uh pills are you
gone any other medications no sir okay
um you have any physical defects glass
eyes artificial limbs anything like that
ITP what is ITP idiopathy
tell me what that is
bruising easily which means 50 000
counts of
platelets to a hundred thousand kinds of
platelets is a normal person's range
okay 150 to 200 000 is a normal person's
range okay so you just you bruise very
easily very easily okay and I bleed and
you believe yourself like are you in a
blood thinners or anything
um no but I am prescribed stuff to make
me clot better if that makes sense yes
okay all right
um other than that any other kind of
physical defects or anything I need to
know about Adderall you're on Adderall
one Adderall
4 or 5 pm today 15 milligrams 15
milligrams okay so besides the Adderall
and the other drug that you told me
about the other prescriptions or
anything else that you're taking
Red Bull okay I understand that
um do you have any physical defects as
far as like anything your neck back legs
Norms knees ankles anything that would
prevent or inhibit your completion of
the exercises no no okay very good all
right
what I want to do put your feet together
put your arms down at your side heels
heels toes to toes
okay can you see the tip of my pen right
here what I want you to spot it I'm
having your eyes only don't move your
head you understand
yes okay
don't anticipate where it's going to go
just follow your eyes
you gotta you gotta follow your eyes
okay
thank you
don't move your head just your eyes
don't don't leave your head do me a
favor take your take your hands go like
this make like a cup like it put them
around your chin like this there you go
okay now and put your hands against your
there you go okay
universities well
Olivia yeah
it's not valid for failure to pay
traffic fine negative 29.
she does have ch on Florida with officer
safety for batteries
she is a current student okay
everything she says right all right
okay
all right
we're gonna we're gonna step right over
there to the uh the clubhouse right
there okay
keep walking we're just gonna go right
by right in those parking spaces right
there all right see this white line
that's right in front of us
okay here's what I want you to do once
you step around in that white line for
me
okay
perfect just say that first are you
comfortable doing this in your shoes or
do you need to take your sandals off
okay if you want to kind of hang on to
your dress a little bit yeah I don't
want you to trip over it okay here's
what I want you to do see how this line
is flat level free to bring in well lit
okay what I want you to do is put your
left foot on the line put your right
front in front of your left heels
touching your toes
heels touch your toes arms down by your
side and don't move from that position
until they tell you to do you understand
do you understand okay when I tell you
to you're going to take a series of nine
steps walking down the line you're gonna
touch Heel To Toe on every step you're
going to look down at your feet you're
going to count each step out loud you're
going to leave your arms to your side
any questions so far no okay after the
ninth step you're gonna turn around and
here's how you're going to do that
you're going to leave your front foot
the heels heels and Toes got to touch
okay
you're gonna turn around here's how you
can do that you're going to leave your
front foot on the line your back foot's
gonna come also let's say
no okay your front foot's gonna stay in
the line your back foot's gonna come off
the line take a series of small steps
and return down the line in the same
manner nine Heel To Toe steps look down
at your feet count each step out loud
and leave your arms to your side once
you begin walking do not stop until
you've completed everything do you
understand correct I'm gonna demonstrate
for you stay just like that for me okay
can you see my feet
it'll look like this one two three all
the way to nine on that ninth step front
foot stays on the line back foot comes
off the line series of small steps and
we're turned on a line in the same
manner one two three all the way to nine
do you understand all those instructions
yes do you have any questions for me do
you need me repeat anything for you
okay you may begin
yes
arms okay here's the next thing what you
do face me feet together arms down your
side heels to heels toes to toes in a
moment what you're going to do is you're
going to raise one leg either leg
approximately six inches off the ground
with your foot pointed out so it's
parallel to the ground while holding
that position you're going to count out
loud in the following manner one
thousand one one thousand two one
thousand three and so on until I tell
you to stop eyes on your elevated foot
arms to your side if you happen to put
your foot down for any reason pick it
back up and keep counting where you left
off do you understand those instructions
yes do you need me repeat anything for
you okay
you can go ahead and begin
look down at your foot
stop
I got one more thing I want to do for me
okay can you see that tree right there
yeah okay here's what I want to do face
tree spread your feet okay nice and wide
okay can you put your thumbs like this
what are your thumbs okay and then
you're gonna put like your skin put it
behind your back like that I want you to
count to 30 for me okay start counting
to 30.
three four five six seven eight nine all
right you are under arrest for driving
under the influence of the chemical
control substance
you're under arrest for DUI please don't
please don't please sir I beg of you
I'm not drunk I will do a breathalyzer
test
come stand with me in front of you okay
come step over here I appreciate letting
me know okay so first thing we're gonna
go is to the DUI Center
yes sir I live oh I was I was oh you
wanna oh just do it I'll do the uh are
you good with it I can take her yeah I
don't care oh okay I'll get a giraffe
and the and the stuff okay oh okay
take me home they got one no you're
gonna go to actually this car
please don't take me to the
okay I will do anything I can you want
to switch out that I'm not
well
I will do anything I just drink under
the job I literally you can breathalize
me right now well at the DUI Center
where you're gonna go to you'll have an
opportunity to take a breath test okay
so this officer is going to take custody
of you
just respond real quick you have
anything else on you no but I have to be
really bad in my vision and support okay
so I had to go all the way to Millennia
yes down that way please no listen we
don't have a choice
716 dispatch
oh
gonna be New Jersey registration
red pickup should come back to uh
Silverado
keys in the middle of the road cell
phone in the Middle Road
how old are you
like five perfect
one defense
there in the back
there's a little spill
pissed on his tire and then took a spill
you got a name
what's the problem
you're sleeping in the middle of the
road
oh on your
your pants are down
oh
are you diabetic I don't know
probably the wrong answer
wallet in the floor
oh
foreign
there's been several calls and another
caller that that's all you get out of
the car and walk to the back
all right so this officer is going to
hop on the rig with you you're gonna go
over RWJ
I drove so much
I I don't know you didn't tell me that
I'm saying that there's been other
callers that
I've seen you driving I'm getting out of
the car
okay who's driving
okay okay
crash wise will happen he rolled up to
this truck he said well he was parked
they came up only passed out
okay so you didn't hit anything
um
until he pulls it out it's rubber on
rubber yeah you can see it's about time
okay
um
is there anybody else in this car
just him
so who's the one that rolled up on him
right here
were you the one that rolled up on him
yeah okay
if you give me a statement about it
briefly what happened though what did
you see so we're checking for spots over
here where you roll up on him and he has
his car on if he slumped over uh we
knocked on the window and he just wasn't
waking up okay
um
do you make any statements to you
anything like that
no he basically no he just he couldn't
he was like this mom boy he's mumbled
yes okay
um you can see his eyes anything like
that
I just smelled it okay was there
anything in the vehicle
like you see like on the floorboard and
the scent holder he has that bottle of
vodka yeah
is it open Yeah okay or I thank you very
much
man he had a ball walking next to him
yeah it was in the it was right next to
him yeah okay in the seat uh kind of
like it's big enough where it covered
the seat and like okay floor I saw cans
but I think that I don't think that's
alcohol I mean it's like energy drinks
or whatnot I'll figure it out a minute
he's in that vehicle yeah that's our guy
on duty like normal Duty yeah because
we're doing the event
did you need oh3s from us we're the ones
that discovered yeah if you wouldn't
mind
um if you could write me out something
on there and then contact information
for you all and who you are so I can get
in touch with you about it all right
okay all right I'll be right back
for Garner how's it going
all right you're gonna come out here
with me you're going to see my car okay
I'm gonna talk to you
all right
no my own
my wife's name
what's going on tonight
step out here with me wrong I've seen my
car okay I'll talk to you
hey brother talk to him so he can come
on man do as much as he can hear my
phone yeah we got it no let him talk to
you again
no I need to step out come on come on no
yes
we talked about this earlier
you were going to cooperate with him I
know you wasn't with me but you're going
to with him I don't want to take you to
jail tonight okay you're going to push
my buttons we'll go straight to jail I'm
not kidding with you okay I understand
what's going on I can smell it come from
your breath
I already know what's going on if you're
starting to push my buttons already if
you're going to be compliant be
compliant if not we can go to jail
and you can figure it out later
okay I'm trying to be polite with you
but you're not one to look me in the eye
you're not even wanting to speak to me
it's your name you just look down okay
Peter Vegas
for garden have you step out with me or
we'll go back to my patrol car okay
please step out
because I can have them transport you to
jail and I can just meet from there it
doesn't matter to me okay so would you
like to step out now come on man stick
this in just stick with him stick with
him just just work with me okay all
right step out man
I need help I'm good
I'm that far back here
are you injured or anything no taking
medications anything like that okay
your contacts for glasses
what's up here for a minute all right
I'm gonna take a look at your eyes
though all right
no
I'm sorry I'm gonna take a look at your
eyes is that okay is that something
you're wanting to do I want me to put
your feet together for me
all right let's hit my fan
okay all right is it something you're
willing to do
okay well uh predicate predicate on
whether or not you take any tests or
anything it's not how I determine yeah
but these are sfsds correct Mike I'm
going to explain it to you real quick
though okay whether or not you refuse it
is not predicated whether or not you go
to jail your attitude determines that
with me okay I'll be upfront with you as
long as you're fighting Cooperative I'll
work with you to get your hold okay but
if you're gonna if you're gonna be a
pain to me let me finish if you're gonna
be a pain about stuff and not let me do
my job we'll just go to jail and I'll
solve the problem for myself that's how
I do it okay so if you don't want to
take this you don't have to you know
that legally as the rest of us do here I
have to offer it to you I have to try to
do what I can do okay I clearly see that
you've been drinking I can smell it on
your breath okay all right I can see it
right now
I just want to go to the wheel I'm just
trying to like you're doing some
Checkers you don't have to but you can
do that's all I'm trying to do so it's
entirely up to you whether or not that's
something you want to do okay
I'm gonna have my cups on you instead so
I can give this young one back his okay
I'll save the other way other way
I have your palm facing in oh it's stuck
if you clap your hands together it's
gonna be a lot less tension is what I'm
trying to do yeah
dude see what she did
I find you under the other car and
everything else
sorry David anything on you have to
worry about no okay
or caught me all right I'm telling you
right now you're under arrest drop or
anything tonight okay okay the right to
remain silent anything you say can't
know you can't see in court you have the
right to talk to a lawyer before advice
before asking any questions if you
can't afford a lawyer want to be
appointed for you for any questions so
desired if you wish to answer questions
now without a lawyer President right
stop answering questions at any time you
also have the right stop answering
questions anytime please talk to your
lawyer and understand